this episode brought to you by the black
tux premium rental suits and tuxedos
delivered
[Music]
oh wow I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to on the
outside of me Oh hot entrance critic
however let you know that my interest in
you isn't purely professional or do I
need skin tight vinyl and a whip timbre
your frigging professional why you
simply acting so really horny I'm just
representing how an out-of-touch gay man
thinks of straight women ask why you
suddenly a white guy and a very annoying
one at that I'll tell you right after I
finish mugging for the camera critic
it's your old friend Joe oh the mocker
the stell chickadees has gotten too dark
for some viewers time I'm here to make
it more kid-friendly colorful and nipple
Isha's you won't get away with this
mocker I know you don't like it but I
was just doing what the studio demanded
yeah but I apologize I'm just trying to
do something more colorful for the kids
oh you don't need to apologize I
understand you're frustrated but why
don't we sit down and talk about it over
some herbal tea okay that does sound
really nice though I won't let the fact
that you're a decent human being get in
front of the fact that you make horrible
crap it's Earl Grey oh I look real great
that's like my favorite no I need
someone who won't fall for your kindness
I need a geek an angry geek a lot angry
geek blast really yeah I feel like
there's a lot of angry geeks millions
okay I don't know why he calls himself
that either bonk calling
[Music]
my storage closet the whole time don't
judge me very much ham all right knocker
it's time it's time to put it into your
insanity now don't be that way
why don't I order us some lattes and we
can sit down and discuss artistic styles
and interpretations he is very nice we
did an entire riff dress on how your
style ruined Batman Forever
you did yes and it's still available for
anyone to purchase cameos by Mike Nelson
Kevin Murphy and Bill Corbett good times
are just a back click away
well that was recorded years ago you
couldn't possibly find any Fault in
Batman Forever now why I don't know I
just needed a segue into the review yeah
there's like a million jokes about this
movie yeah we should probably just get
to it Batman forever after the 1989
smash hit Batman producers were excited
to see if the follow-up Batman Returns
would deliver as big a financial punch
the film didn't quite deliver what the
studio wanted with many parents
complaining it was too dark for children
this resulted in child-friendly
merchandise being pulled most notably
McDonald's Happy Meal toys not wanting
to go through that again the studio
pushed director Tim Burton into a
producing role and handed control over
to Joel Schumacher he agreed to make the
third installment Batman Forever more
lighthearted and marketable and it
seemed to pay off as it made more money
than the previous installment Schumacher
is best known for his following epic ice
puns an ass but a lot of people ignore
what a cluster of goofiness Batman
Forever is seemingly giving it a pass
we're here see if that pass is warranted
or if it deserves to be tossed in the
Snyder pile pile of what you know what
let's take a look at this Bechet
insanity with Batman Forever after being
assaulted by the big names in this movie
interpret that as you will we see Batman
played this time by Val Kilmer getting
ready to write a Batmobile so fat like
that even HR Giger original design look
less penis II and if you think they're
not gonna over correct the Happy Meal
tie in from the last film take a look at
this actual opening line can I persuade
you to take a sandwich with you sir
get drive-through well came act like
they didn't set the bar low from the
very start it's such a weird line clear
we've done just for a McDonald's ad can
I persuade you to take a sandwich with
you sir I'll get drive-through tomatoes
crisp lettuce two cheeses on a superhero
bun it doesn't fit in the movie at all
the only way it could work is if it was
literally followed by this can I
persuade you to take a sandwich with you
sir
I'll get drive-through two cheeseburgers
a large fries and I got a movie out so
just give me whatever plastic schlock
with my face on it you got bingo
Batman drives to the second Bank of
Gotham in Chinatown as a crime boss
named two-face played by Tommy Lee Jones
instead of Billy Dee Williams only the
finest of art forms remedy this you know
I love the Italian mobster in that he's
robbing a bank and juggling his split
personality of a district attorney and a
purple monkey you know Tommy Lee Jones
told Jim Carrey he hated him because he
couldn't sanction his buffoonery the
blood drained from his face and hugged
me and said I hate you I cannot sanction
your buffoonery
make sense to me I'm just wondering how
acid can turn one half of your face into
plastic purple latex as you probably
guess he often flips a coin to decide
who lives and who dies fortune smiles
another day of wine and roses
[Music]
I mean I'll kill ya later ba-bling you
live for a few minutes I'm a district
attorney I can always find a loophole
that man arrives on the scene to meet up
with psychiatrist dr. chase meridian
played by nicole kidman high entrance a
dedicated professional as you can see
Goren is trying to figure out how to
save the hostages inside but Batman has
more important issues to confront like
convincing a stranger that bats aren't
rodents I could write a hell of a paper
on a grown man who dresses like a flying
rodent oh no you didn't bets aren't
rodents dr. Meridian you are interesting
your ability to wiki search intrigues me
by the way do you know the first thing
or do they just call you beds Oh what is
there a bank robbery yourself oh yeah
there totally is well we don't dr.
vurdien sure did Batman breaks in and
fights off a gang of Mexican wrestlers
also trying to get the cameraman a
tripod
does that device turn people to Roger
Rabbit Oh
apparently it's spread to the music to
let the composer run out of money so we
just ran through poser to face lifts the
vault into the air filling it with acid
to rain down on the people of Gotham and
their multicolored windows medieval
times is more civil with their color use
he uses his grappling hook to break
through the incredibly weak concrete
which also supports a giant metal safe
because it's suddenly the strongest
concrete in the world I knew they
shouldn't have used this stuff to face
flies his helicopter towards the Statue
of Gotham II it was a gift from French
metropolis a both two-faced and Batman
jump out in time leading to
[Music]
can we just start a pointless Schumacher
slow-mo count well if I could start a
valvular mouth hanging open count but
that clashes with my Christian Bale
mouth hanging open count let's look at
the menu if you share the slo-mo count
with a Jim Carrey making an excited he
farted face count and you can share the
val kilmer mouth hanging open count with
christian bale's mouth hanging open
count and who gets the bad news we all
do Harvey two-face is still at large and
extremely dangerous
Wow Batman the Animated Series did not
age well that's supposed to look
realistic it's not I know it's not
speaking of which were introduced to Jim
Carrey as Edward nygma huh names so
ridiculous even the animated series
refused to believe he didn't just make
it up what did you mean a joke on his
name his name's Edward nygma enigma
Edward Edward nygma look at us at first
I thought Carrie's portrayal of nygma
was a little too over the top but after
internet culture and fanboys blew up
yeah it might be too subtle thing was
obsessed with Bruce Wayne and wants him
to okay his device that beams TV signals
directly into the human brain I'm
sorrier than the answer's no tampering
with people's brainwaves mind
manipulation it just sounds like cable
news it just raises too many questions
what just least you can actually
pinpoint the second when his heart rips
in half no Bruce sees the bat-signal and
uses the bath pipe to transport himself
to the Batcave that must have been a lot
of fun for the builders to put in Alfred
threw his back out a lot after setting
that up chair
duskie really see no problem rising with
that setup boy this is a really
comfortable chair it turns out the call
came from dr. meridian Commissioner
Gordon
he's at home I sent a signal no trust me
you're sending all the signals and thus
we partake in one-liner theatre you're
trying to get under my cape doctor a
girl can't leave by psychoses alone it's
the car right to club the car oh I know
they open in line for the next film
black rapper try fireman less to take
off this is sexual harassment and I
don't have to take it my life is an open
book you read I'll bring the wine
you bring your scarred psyche or do I
need skin tight vinyl inner with a lady
what's your PhD and bad pickup lines
come to think of it what was she shaking
earlier Commissioner Gordon that blocks
them showing up in his pajamas no false
alarm
are you sure he's so wish there was an
emergency just so I could see him fight
crime in his pajamas oh you saw my
director's cut
megamouth meanwhile kidnaps his boss and
uses his device on him yeah you made
spike its 3d and because this film isn't
subtle enough
clearly dignity has been returned to the
dark night after stealing his brainwaves
nygma kills his boss and were shown the
most cinematic court show ever was
horribly scarred Maroni
although Batman tried to save him dents
left brain damage well there you go one
third of the Dark Knight movie condensed
into two sentences shouldn't he want
revenge on the crime boss also as Batman
testifying in court it's he a valid
witness if no one knows who he is it
just raises too many questions no shit
Bruce has given a riddle in his office
after it's revealed that nygma's boss
seems to have jumped to his death
best Commissioner ever meanwhile we see
Wayne Enterprises apparently hands out
really shitty paychecks as nygma's home
slash someone else's closet is being
used to send more threatening riddles
first takes one of them to a hmm
professional doctor Meridian figure out
the rest
Bruce here's threatening sounds from our
office but it looks like she was just
doing her usual in-office boxing before
a session are you sure he's supposed to
be the crazy-looking one here and of
course he gets her in depth expert
advice at this point I'd actually trust
Wakko more than you his only escape may
be to purge the fixation so not only is
he a wacko but you've jumped to the
conclusion that he's a guy I think we
establish he's not a good psychiatrist
the two of them hit it off I guess they
more play iSpy of obvious symbolism in
the room you have a thing for bats
she's a Malaysian dream warden she
protects you from bad dreams and he
invites her to the Gotham charity circus
a Joel Schumacher film you say
[Music]
Schumacher who looks at men the same way
Michael Bailey looks at women and men
the more I think about it it's here that
we're introduced to the flying Grayson's
one of them soon to be Robin the 25 year
old Boy Wonder
I'm totally 15 you guys I'm like into
Pokemon or whatever but two-face
interrupts the televised circus
performance you know those common circus
performances you see all the time on TV
and tells the crowd that if Batman's
identity isn't revealed he'll blow
everybody up Batman
bruised broken the grace is trying to
stop the bomb but two-face guns them
down leaving only dick
some days you just can't get rid of a
bomb the day is saved but young Grayson
is left without a family
to demonstrate Schumacher's
understanding of this tremendous loss
we cut immediately to a horse helping
Iraq okay I'm out of here
excuse me okay figure telling that cop
I'd stay here for a while save me a
truckload of Social Service interviews
and charity so uh no offense but no
thanks
well you're legally an adult so do
whatever the hell you want your fix on
two-face I want to kill him
feeling two-faced won't take the pain
away make it worse I mean I felt great
when I killed the Joker but it probably
wouldn't fit you
Bruce's forget your parents and fix my
bike which deck immediately agrees to
but it looks like Batman is being called
to an emergency that will never be
addressed so Alfred is left to tend to
Bruce's dick I know what I said is this
Robin my brother's wire bro he swung out
and grabbed him my father said I was
just here
I flew in like a Robin some hero I
turned out to be but your father was
right
the first time anyway meanwhile two-face
ambushes Batman on his way to the crime
will never see as once again were
introduced to the world's strongest
frickin grappling hook
[Music]
tune in next time kids same Bechet
impossibility same Bechet way meanwhile
nygma is trying to figure out what to
call his alternate identity but his
Geico caveman puppet apparently has an
idea thank you
I shall be the green light bulb
meanwhile two-face salts in his split
lair yeah that's complex's as character
it's gonna get folks well apparently the
real lair is waiting there too don't
mind me I'll just be waiting for the ass
Cystic director to cue me I made your
favorite
a stir no and grain alcohol harness drew
Barrymore calls it a starter we're two
minds about what to eat first
the great white bulb the river comes out
of literally hiding it says he can help
him kill Batman if two-face lets him
live Batman post
did you enjoy my pork impression the
combination of Max Headroom and a green
skin tells to face that if he gets his
device on every television in town he'll
help him get Batman two-face reluctantly
agrees reluctant for him or my quiet
they robbed every place they can to
mass-produce his invention
ah his superpower is to magically shrink
diamonds mean edit teamed with to face
this new criminals pattern of marking
his crimes with puzzles as Gothamites
calling him the Riddler when they be
calling him the ripoff artist I mean
obviously the Riddler type character
exists in this world from all the toys
Mingma had so why don't people recognize
it it'd be like if a killer wore a
spider-man costume and call himself the
Red Lobster and sure that would be a
better name how my spiders are red
[Applause]
you
[Music]
I need a tuxedo but I'm far too busy to
go to a place with people to get one too
busy talking to this wall then I'm
convinced as an online audience well
that's why I contacted the black tux
comm so they can mail me one wall why
Thank You mailman it wasn't really there
cardboard box you said you were sending
me a Tatsu liar oh there's a tuxedo in
the box good I mean everyone wants to
look good for that special event but
they don't want to fork out a ton of
money for it either
well the black tux com is your answer
with high quality rental suits and
tuxedos delivered to your doorstep it's
such an easy way to rent suits and tuxes
online most suits go for something like
1,200 bucks but at the black tux they
start at $95 they let you create your
own look and choose from a ton of great
stylist their expert customer care has
your back every step of the way and it's
completely done online you can even do a
free home try on so you can see the fit
and feel the quality of your suit months
before your big event and after ordering
your suit they'll have it to you 14 days
before the event even starts it even
comes with socks free socks and if
anything is less than perfect the black
tux will send you a free replacement
right away when your event is over you
just drop your rental back in the mail
and shipping is free both ways and hey
you want to get 20 bucks off your
purchase just visit the black tux comm
slash nostalgia critic that's right just
go to the black tux consolation
nostalgia Creek and you'll get $20 right
off your purchase now I'm ready for my
incredibly big event
[Music]
some people still see snow as a special
occasion visit the black tux comm
premium rental suits and tuxedos
delivered
[Music]
pigma gets enough money to sell his
device and even finally gives it a name
the box in every home in America it's a
toner edward nygma's 3d boxes it's a
cone
critics have claimed the box turns got
the mic code there's hardly a home
without the nygma tech box the box oh
why you have such a problem saying
you're watching Jim Carrey's box now I
get it
meanwhile Alfred wants to make sure he
can use the entrance to the Batcave
while his dick is occupied yes sheesh
you can hop on one foot and catch up to
the door in time yeah Batman's guessing
the hard core security there and
everything turned on while a meek voice
goes intruder alert didn't you hear the
voice it called us intruders think about
death was character before cultures
ruffian oh wait
meanwhile Bruce and chase get ready for
their date Bruce opens with his most
romantic phrases my parents were
murdered in front of me that's just a
kid you really know all the pickup lines
but he literally gets jealous of himself
as chase leaves her bet porn out maybe
I'll leave you two alone well try not
posing with a smile on the cover of Time
you egomaniac did you get my bad side
but Alfred lets him know that dick has
gone travelling as he cruises around
town in the Batmobile
not bad man oh yeah I'm like totally a
little kid I'm watching Ben 10 or
whatever man
oh wait that's the circuit skip Bruce
Wayne and sweeps totally Batman genius
to figure that out I'm gonna put it on
snapchat it looks like a girl is in
trouble at this laser tag arcade but
good hearty dick is on the way to save
her he's defeated
but the gang language of a whistle
signals the other members to attack
hello Batman here trying to look
threatening not for crying out loud
Batman saves him after getting his cape
caught no really that happens getting
some harsh reactions from his dick if
Bruce Wayne could have given his life
for your family he would have dumbass
Bruce goes to wipe the sweat away lord
knows it took a lot out of him to jump
and that's it as he makes it clear that
Grayson don't know dick so you're
willing to take a life it will happen
this way you make the kill yeah but your
pain isn't tied with Harvey it grows Oh
so you run out into the night to find
another face this is literally my dream
you know that Bruce I'm a part of this
whether you like it or not what are you
gonna do replace me with Joseph
gordon-levitt so everyone gathers to see
the new version of Nima's box tone let
it go as nygma seems to be the toast of
the town
[Music]
No is everyone's acting channeling a
constant orgasm make that's bad check
out this guy who try something his
latest invention with that guy like a
rabid baboon would be less awkward shall
we dance I was asking you so while
therapists and the world's greatest
detective couldn't figure out this is
the Riddler Wade has duped into a
mind-reading machine which is
interrupted by to face this he has time
for him to break free and once again
refused to enter through a door
are there any normal extras in this
movie they put on a stunt show and try
doing their version of the Raiders of
the Lost Ark gun scene it doesn't work
don't worry we don't blame you stuff man
not in any way resembling Val Kilmer as
two-face moves on to phase two by the
way I can't sanction your buffoonery
look we have two pointless slo-moes and
two Kilmer's mouths hanging open and yet
I feel so empty
but two-face blasts him under a mountain
of sand enjoy its costs roughen gets
everywhere but his dick saves him making
Bruce surprisingly unhappy what the hell
did you think you were doing I had it
out from this movie they bicker and
argue but Bruce has no time for that
he's got a horny honey he's secretly
stalking and shea sickles being Batman
occurs never been in love before
she seems hot entrance what is it about
the wrong kind of man do I need skin
tight vinyl in with honestly I think
she's a creepier fan than nygma
nevertheless Batman visits her and she
admits she's more in love with Bruce
than him it's not even as personality
it's just something about his jawline oh
come on and this of course gives us the
bat nope Oh
however nygma shows us the results of a
Bruce Wayne mind-reading brittlely
what kind of a man is bats Aquaman well
that's going on Batman decides to give
up his night job
from this day on Batman is no more
chases coming over for dinner I'm going
to tell her everything
so just remember folks it wasn't a
supervillain or a dangerous stunt that
ended Batman's career it was a horny
psychologist and his whiny dick actually
that makes a little too much sense
Bruce invites chase over to tell her
everything while kids go
trick-or-treating at his house release
the hounds as Bruce continues to have
flashbacks his dick flees in disgrace
and the Riddler and two-face find a way
to sneak in and don't forget to move
that tray away from the door there you
go they blow up the Batcave kidnapped
chase meridian and two-face keeps
flipping his coin until he gets the side
he wants just like the comic
I can't sanction this buffoon now with
too much buffoonery if you kill him as
Bruce wakes up he's told what happened
and the Riddler gets to continue his
annoying Jim Carrey impression I'd say
this is over the top even for him but
seeing how the rest of Gotham acts I see
he fits right in Catwoman who do you
think
meanwhile Bruce and Alfred try to figure
out the meaning of the riddles realizing
there's a number in each one and perhaps
they represent the alphabet 18 is M mr.
e and another name for mr. e enigma mr.
enigma Edward nygma there's also a
return address from Edward nygma
industries but your way were too and if
for a split second you forgot Joel
Schumacher directed this but he's not
the only one who has to look ridiculous
what's that's ten-four Ralf I just
always wanted to be called Ralf
that man is rather easily convinced to
let him come along now as they go to
stop the evildoers thankfully Batman
also lets the police know they don't
actually have to do their jobs
[Music]
well I guess our work is done meanwhile
at Nickelodeon studios the Riddler and
two-face try to foil our dynamic duo
Oh doh my dick hi we've had a lot of fun
with people named dick today but they're
all good sports so the next time you see
your local dick why not go up to them
say
I know it's hard dick you know between
the Joker's gun and a green light the
batplane is pathetically easy to take
down isn't it fully rusted metal Batman
crowd it's all metal it's full of holes
you holy Oh
Oh we gotcha the movie wouldn't be so
silly to put that kind of line in there
however lines like this you're trying to
get into my cape doctor and this
I'll get drive-thru and this car ride to
club the car are totally fine the tour
separated leaving Robin to fight to face
alone
[Music]
you never bet I hope you have a small
family man reaches the riddler who looks
like Elton John Liberace and syndrome
fused by Satan as he reveals his evil
plan my little box will be on countless
TVs around the world feeding me credit
card numbers bank codes sexual fantasies
and little white lies wow that's
actually kind of relevant yeah like
legit clever commentary I am not saying
this is ahead of its time I am NOT
saying this is ahead of its time he
shows that he captured Chase and Robin
in fact he weirdly looks less shocked
that Robin is captured than chase
seriously day one and you got caught and
the Riddler makes him choose which one
dies which one will it be Batman Bruce's
love or the Dark Knight's junior partner
I'll have the lasagna but Batman seems
to have a riddle for the Riddler
I see without seeing to me darkness is
as clear as daylight what am I the
riders you're blind
exactly he puts on his computer specs
because he needed help to hit the giant
blender in the middle of the room and
the Riddler's turned into
pizza dough I have no idea
the Riddler ends up dropping them but
thankfully Batman's ego weighs more than
them so he's able to defy the laws of
gravity disable in answer to what I
choose to make my I choose the same that
spider-man took you're welcome it was a
mistake bringing you and I'm never doing
this again
I like curtains what you forgetting
something Harvey your coin you're always
two minds about everything except when
it's not which we've established is most
of the time that man makes it clear
that's wrong for Robin to kill but him
on the other hand he can totally keep
looking for other faces to kill and this
one is two for one he kind of explains
this to nygma oh I should have gotten
vaccinated
you see I'm both Bruce Wayne and Batman
not because I have to be now
because I choose to be did I mention I'm
not gonna be in the next Batman movie
he's sent to Arkham Asylum where the
doctor is concerned about what he knows
Edward nygma has been screaming for
hours that he knows the true identity of
Batman and why my name is in the opening
credits even though I only have one lime
dr. Burton tells me Ben Affleck okay
he's clearly nuts
Bruce says goodbye to chase so I guess
he did choose Batman over Bruce Wayne
kind of cheating and our dynamic duds
run triumphant ish into the night ha
holds up pretty well doesn't it well
while we appreciate you standing there
in silence the whole time yeah I like to
listen we still can't say it's a good
Batman movie I mean okay it's not Batman
and Robin and it's meant to be lighter
in tone but it just seems confused on
whether it wants to be a comedy like the
Adam West show a drama like the Burton
movies if as it turns out it doesn't
succeed in either granted it does have a
few good ideas and the visuals are still
rather stunning in many respects but it
plays everything too safe and that's not
how Batman should be handled Batman
should be different memorable and
inspired this film is either annoyingly
odd or boring we generic if it didn't
have the Batman name on it it'd probably
be forgotten quickly it's a superhero
flick it's not the worst but it's not
that good either
it's a strange installment but not
strange enough to leave that big of an
impact well I respect your opinion come
on why don't we all sit down and have
some tea together I've already made some
for Malcolm and Tamara he really is a
nice guy
[Music]
you know why not yeah I mean I know I
don't always like your movies mocker but
you seem like a decent down-to-earth guy
well I really appreciate that
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
Gotham must know
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing the
cancer Research Institute since 1953
they've led the field with support for
immune therapy research and clinical
trials together with their donor patient
and scientist communities they continue
to fund revolutionary breakthroughs to
cure all types of cancer by harnessing
the innate powers of the body's immune
system immune therapy treatments have
the potential to achieve complete
long-lasting remissions and cures if you
look at their site or their YouTube page
you can see all the hard work that goes
into this fight and all the patients
they've helped or saved along the way
there's still so much more work that
needs to be done and you can play a big
part in making history simply by giving
a little donation click on the link
below and see how you can help make a
huge difference
[Music]
you